today on the matt walsh show as we head
into so-called pride month
the lgbt propaganda is going into
overdrive the children's show blues
clues kicks things off with an episode
featuring a drag queen a pride parade
and pansexuals also five headlines
including
more sexual indoctrination of children
this time a graphic video about
masturbation
which was shown to six-year-olds at a
school in new york city
and an nba all-star says that he's the
victim of the underlying racism of nba
fans
in our daily cancellation we'll talk
about the obese woman who says
that you are morally obligated to find
her attractive you don't have a choice
in the matter all of that and more today
on the matt wall show
you know it's important not to idealize
the past
the world during my childhood certainly
wasn't perfect the media we consumed at
the time wasn't perfect either
but one thing i do remember is that
children's shows were
broadly speaking shows for children they
had
childish themes and ideas and plots the
moral at the end of every story was
always something like
sharing is good or learning is fun
and this all made a lot of sense the
show blues clues was
a little bit after my time it debuted
when i was in middle school i think if i
remember correctly but my younger
siblings were
blues clues fanatics so i was exposed to
the show a fair amount
during a typical episode blue the
cartoon dog would decide that he wanted
to
you know make puppets out of
construction paper or something and then
he discovered that his scissors are
missing
and with the help of his human friend
steve and the children watching at home
blue would search around the house for
his scissors and then he would
eventually find the scissors
and that would be the end of the episode
suspense drama
sorrow redemption the show had it all or
at least it had enough
for the preschoolers in the audience
those preschoolers they don't need much
from their
entertainment innocent and simple should
be the name of the game
and that's what many children's shows
used to be that's what blue's clues used
to be
but not anymore like so many other forms
of child entertainment blues clues went
from
looking for his scissors to this
families marching one by one hurrah
hurrah
families marching one by one hurrah
hurrah
this family has two mummies they love
each other so proudly and they all
go marching in the big
parade families marching two by two
hurrah
hurrah families marching two by two
hurrah
this family has two daddies they love
each other so proudly and they all
go marching in the big
parade come on friends family's marching
three by three hurrah
[Music]
are non-binary they love each other so
proudly and they all
go marching in the big
parade
yes a non-binary disabled dolphin
and i also i hope you notice the uh
black lives matter fist on the
microphone so they really they really
jammed it all in there
yes that is a pride parade featured on a
recent episode of the show blues
excludes
a show which again is targeted
specifically at children aged three to
five
the person singing is a man named andrew
levitt who goes by
nina west when he's on stage as a drag
queen
and that's apparently not the first time
that blue's clues has delved into lgbt
propaganda they recently released a
video featuring young children talking
about the different pride flags and what
they mean
there are of course many pride flags to
signify many different sexual
proclivities
the parade segment we just watched goes
on for a while listing many of them
starting with gay and lesbian and then
as you saw
disabled non-binary dolphins and then
into trans and beyond
let's watch a little more just to see
how far
this actually goes families marching six
by six hurrah
hurrah families marching six by six
hurrah
hurrah hey spy and pan grown-ups you see
can love each other so proudly and they
all go
marching in the big parade
oh yeah ace bye
and pan sound like the names of
you know members of a boy band or
something but uh no a spy and pam
because it's important that that
three-year-olds
be taught about pansexuals by the way if
you're wondering what ace means i had to
look that up
that's a term used for asexuals now if
you're wondering why asexuals that is
people who experience
no sexual attraction at all are included
in a community of people who identify
themselves
by their attraction to other people and
why anyone would be proud of not being
attracted to other humans anyway
well that i can't really explain all i
can say is that the lgbt umbrella has
become more like a mushroom
growing and growing until it has reached
now a point where it's defined
not by what it is but by what it isn't
the only similarity between an asexual
someone who isn't attracted to anybody
and a pansexual someone who's attracted
to everybody
is that neither are heterosexual the
point of pride for lgbt people these
days
seems to simply be that they aren't
straight
it's not a gay pride parade it's it's a
not
straight parade it's all about what you
aren't
it's not really about what you are this
is an important fact to keep in mind
especially as we enter into what has now
been deemed pride month
it used to be you know you had a one
part of a day the pride parade and then
it was pride day and then
it was a week and now it's pride month
many corporation institutions
corporations and institutions will go
out of their way this month even more
than they do every other month to push
this agenda on to the public and
especially onto kids
kellogg's for example recently unveiled
a pride cereal
developed in association with the gay
activist group glaad
the marketing campaign declares that
boxes are for serial
not people and on the side of the box
there's a list of pronouns with a couple
of blank spaces so that kids can fill in
their own pronouns if they want
ironically they say boxes are for serial
not people and then invite children to
literally put themselves into a box
indeed the lgbt movement is all about
boxes
it's all about obsessively identifying
and labeling people
the last thing they want is for children
to be free and unencumbered able to
explore the world
figure themselves out from a very young
age
they say to the kids here are the labels
now pick one for yourself and assume an
identity that coincides with it
of course they'll never be honest about
any of this
the fact the absolutely undeniable
indisputable fact which is staring us
right in the face
is that the cultural powers that be
really
desperately want your kid to be gay or
trans
or some variation thereof and they are
going to do what they can
to make that happen
but they won't admit it instead they'll
tell you that all of this pride
parades and pansexuals in schools and in
shows for three-year-olds
non-binary pronouns on cereal boxes etc
all of this is about inviting kids to be
themselves they'll say
it's about inviting the three-year-olds
who are already
trans or gay or pansexual to simply come
out and and live their authentic truth
now if you're still buying that line
then you may be a hopeless case
i don't know what to tell you i can't
force oblivious people to use their
brains if they've gotten so comfortable
living without them
but for everybody else the truth should
be clear by now
this of course has nothing to do with
inviting kids to be who they are
there are no transgender three-year-olds
or bisexual three-year-olds
or pansexual three-year-olds
three-year-olds are not concerned with
expressing their sexual identities
mostly because they don't have a sexual
identity at that age
they're concerned mostly with eating
snacks and running around without their
shoes on
and playing with their toys if we wanted
to help them live
their truth quote unquote that's the
truth we would help them live
this hyper sexualization this incense
incessant propagandizing
is rather about introducing a new quote
truth
it's about turning them into something
that they would not otherwise be
and as we already covered the identity
that our most powerful cultural
institutions
want a child to adopt is a negative
identity
the message to the child is simple in a
way it's simple
what you want to be be who you want to
be
but don't be straight don't be quote
cisgender
don't adopt any values or worldviews or
ideas that your grandparents may have
held
so be whoever you want to be just not
that
here are your boxes there are a lot of
boxes
but you have to choose one and choose it
early
and find your identity and your purpose
in it
that's the message though the people
spreading that message
will never be honest about it
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well it should be clear from what we
just talked about and from
everything that you're seeing happening
in the world generally that uh the most
powerful
institutions in the culture are aligned
against
you and us as conservatives and that's
why it's so important to support
companies
who share similar morals as as you there
aren't a lot of them out there but there
are some
and it's really important to support
them like charity mobile charity mobile
is the pro-life phone company because
five percent of your monthly plan price
goes to the pro-life
pro family charity of your choice and
you're helping to build a culture of
life in america while supporting a
pro-life phone company so it's a win-win
part of that win-win though is that
you're also getting a great service new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping
there's no contracts there's no
termination fees there's no risk with a
30-day guarantee
you also get live customer service based
right here in the usa
and uh if you you know it's all about
convenience as well so you get free
usage alerts you get
a free app to monitor usage and pay your
bill and more
and all the while you're turning
everyday living into effortless giving
that's the motto over at charity mobile
and for good reason so call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com
new lower monthly plan prices and a new
plan with a higher limit higher data
limit
existing customers automatically get the
new lowered plan prices so no need to
contact them and ask for them again
that's charitymobile.com
all right you know i i get accused of
being uh anti-social
mostly because i am anti-social
but one of the reasons why i get this
exhibition is i'm not big into small
talk i'm not a big small talk
it's not that i don't like talk i talk
for a living i just don't i'm not into
smoke this idea that
like any time you're around someone you
have to fill that space
with by making noise with your mouth it
doesn't matter what you're saying
because that's what small talk is
and it annoys me to no end and i
experienced over the weekend
maybe the worst example of this
in my life we were we were out for
memorial day we were at a lake
and i was walking to the car to get
something and i noticed that my
shoes were untied so i stopped to tie my
shoes
and there was this guy walking by and
we're the only ones in the
in the area for a moment and so he's one
of these small talkers and he feels like
okay in his mind i guess he's thinking
i'm gonna i'm gonna be passing by this
other guy
and we're gonna be in the same vicinity
for five seconds and so i have to say
something to
him and so this guy what he says is he's
passing by he says
ah tying your shoes huh he actually said
that
and i look up and i said yep
tie my shoes and then he just kept
walking
why do people what why do people do that
why
why do you fee you obviously had nothing
to say to me at all
that's perfectly fine just say nothing
keep walking
tying your shoes huh is that supposed to
spark a conversation
and then i feel like the anti-social one
because i don't know how to respond to
that i'm not sure what i'm supposed to
say
is that supposed to be the beginning of
a conversation i don't know
you know they say if you don't have
anything nice to say don't say anything
at all and i don't really agree with
that because if i followed that rule
this show wouldn't exist
um but i think it's more like if you
don't have anything to say
period then don't say anything i don't
care if it's nice or not
only speak when you have something to
say and then we do away with small talk
entirely
all right um that was just a a little
break because we have to dive
back in number one here back into the
sexualization of children
unfortunately um
this is number one from the daily wire
it says parents at new york city's
elite private dalton school have come
out in force against videos dealing with
the topic of masturbation
that were shown to their first grade
children
okay keep in mind these are first grade
children we're talking about
what are you first grade six or seven
years old
parents who send their children to the
55 000 a year school have bombarded the
school with complaints about
about dalton director of health and
wellness justine ang fonte's curriculum
according to the new york post report
fonte or font i don't know how to
pronounce the last name
showed six year olds six year olds a
cartoon during her sex ed class that
featured small children discussing
touching themselves
quote because it feels good now
we actually have um some of this video
that
the thing is here i don't even know i
feel uncomfortable playing this
assuming that my audience is adults but
this was played for six year olds
and i am going to play it because this
is the kind of thing
and if you think this is only happening
at ritzy expensive private schools in
new york
you got another thing coming so this is
the kind of thing kids are being exposed
to
we as adults should should know that
this is what's going on
and so in that spirit i present to you
uh this video which again was shown to
six-year-olds at the school in new york
here it is
hey how come my penis gets big sometimes
and points up in the air
that's called an erection sometimes i
touch my penis because it feels good
sometimes when i'm in my bath or when
mom puts me to bed
i like to touch my vulva too you have a
clitoris there kayla that probably feels
good to touch the same way
keith's penis feels good when he touches
it but have you ever noticed that
older kids and grown-ups don't touch
their private parts in public
hmm they don't that's right keith
it's okay to touch yourself and see how
different body parts feel
but it's best to only do it in private
well
if private parts are so special why do
you cover them up
because they are private silly
that's right kayla because they are
private
hey squeaks pass it wait
okay i'm ready
oh my god um
so first of all
justine fonte
um she is uh as far as i'm concerned
this woman is no better than a sex
predator i would say she is a sex player
by my
by my uh standards
and you know in a in a normal sane
healthy society she would be in prison
like
you show that kid that video to kids
and you go to prison as a sex offender
if if you think that that's too far or
it seems a little extreme
then then you know what i always say
with these sex ed things and like i said
this is not
this is maybe a little bit further
than most sex ed curricula will go but
it's not that much further
um but as i the the the uh thought
exercise that i'm always
encouraging for these kinds of things is
just imagine
how it would sound if an adult
stranger went up to some six-year-old
kid at a playground
and said that this is a good
rule of thumb if you're a teacher okay
if whatever you're saying to a kid
if you said that same exact thing
outside of the classroom at a playground
and it would get you arrested in that
context then don't say it in the
classroom
you disgusting creep there's nothing
magical about the classroom where all of
a sudden these things become appropriate
there's also nothing magical about your
status
as a teacher or a quote-unquote educator
as you would call yourself i don't call
this education at all this is grooming
so i put quotes around education no this
is this is not education this is
grooming
this is sexual grooming but there's
nothing magical about that status
that gives you permission
this we kids are sent to school
to learn facts to learn to learn
abc one two three
that's what they're sent to school for i
mean this whole idea that well
just because the kids are sent into the
school building that means that now
you're the parent
and you have carte blanche to say
whatever you want to them
but that's that's how that's have to so
so imagine
that exact conversation between a parent
and let's say some
random 45 year old guy at a playground
talking to the kid about his erection
and telling him that it feels good to
touch himself
there's no question that person would be
arrested and thrown in prison
and nobody would object now you take
that same guy
put him in a classroom with the exact
same kid
so just take that conversation and move
it to a different location
move it from the playground next to the
slide
into the classroom next to the
chalkboard
and now it's okay why how
that's what this is this is this is
grooming of children this is uh
has nothing to do with education
that's what all quote unquote
comprehensive sex ed is that's why i'm
always railing about it
and i and i uh i'm i'm happy that these
parents at this school
are speaking out against this and
apparently they didn't know that this
video was going to be shown
and i mean i believe them that they
didn't know
because as a parent you would have to be
a full-on maniac
to see that video ahead of time and say
oh yeah go ahead and show that to my kid
you know what yeah that's a conversation
i want you to have with my six-year-old
if you're a parent and you really think
you need to have that conversation with
your six-year-old which by the way
you don't
this is uncomfortable to even talk about
but what a
six-year-old masturbating what are you
what
um so nobody needs to have this
conversation with a six-year-old but if
you're a parent
and for some reason you think you need
to have this conversation
with a kid what parent would say oh yeah
i want you this stranger in the class
you have it with him
not me
so i so the parents didn't know the
video was going to be shown they're
speaking out against it
that's great um and they need to go
they need to go beyond speaking out
against they need to to demand that
people are fired over this
i mean everybody at the school who was
involved in showing this video
knew that it was going to be shown all
of them need to be gone fired
at a minimum but at the same time these
parents also
knew presumably that their kids they at
least knew that their kids were insect
said they knew that that was happening
so you knew that your six-year-old was
in us was going to be in a sex ed
class that should be you don't need you
shouldn't even need to know
what kind of material is being taught
you should already be stepping in and
saying uh-uh no
not appropriate this is not what i need
you talking to my six-year-old about
teach them how to spell teach them how
to read that's what we're paying you
people for
i don't need you talking about sex
that's not a conversation you need to
have the way i think i think now is also
a good time to uh remind everyone
that um sex abuse is
an epidemic in the school system sex
abuse is
is is at a crisis level in the school
system and has been for years
nobody cares i mean i've been talking
about this fact for years
and nobody cares i've written about it
there is a full-on sex abuse epidemic in
the school system
right now i mean thousands
of of teachers abusing students
millions of kids have been abused not an
exaggeration
nobody cares maybe now they'll start
caring i don't know
but there's a there's a connection here
maybe you could see it
why do you think so many of these people
that run that are in these schools
whether it's private or public why are
they so interested in talking to kids
about sex
at such a young age and so graphically
a lot of these people are predators
their predations may they maybe have not
been arrested for it yet
some of them maybe have been then they
get moved around
but most of them have not been but
they're predators
we see you know every other week we see
another story about a you know some
some grown woman in a school system
having sex with a 12 year old boy
well these are the same people doing the
sex ed classes
maybe we can start connecting these dots
here
it's amazing to me an epidemic of of sex
abuse
it documented epidemic
which which is just so you know the the
sexual abuse epidemic in the school
system
is way worse than the epidemic
ever was in the catholic church
and it was bad in the catholic church
and i've talked about that too many
times
i have no problem talking about that and
calling that out
but um the the epidemic in the school
system
endorse the the problem in the church
and yeah you've got a lot of parents who
aren't even catholic
don't send their kids to catholic to a
catholic school or
uh or to a church they're never around
priests at all
and they've been way more concerned
about the sex abuse epidemic in the
church
than they are about the sex abuse
epidemic in the schools
where they send their kids
why is that well it's just cowardice
you know it's the same reason why
parents allow these sex ed classes to
happen in the first place and then
complain after the fact when some of the
with some of the material is a little
more graphic than they expected
oh i knew you're going to talk
graphically to my kid about sex i just
didn't know it would be that graphic
they're cowards they don't want to rock
the boat and also they uh they don't
want to make
lifestyle changes themselves
you know they don't have to make any
changes themselves it's much easier to
worry about the problems that are far
off not affecting you don't require any
changes on your part
well anyone in the audience pretending
they didn't know that there's a sex
abuse epidemic in the school now you
don't have that excuse anymore because
it exists it's happening you can look it
up
and it continues to happen because
nobody does anything about it or cares
um okay let's go number two brooklyn
nets guard kyrie irving was
playing at boston on sunday and got
pelted by a water bottle
by a fan i don't i don't really know
what led up to this or why it happened
uh i
well i from what i heard he was stomping
on the celtics logo or something like
that i don't know if you did it
in that game or before it doesn't matter
uh a fan through a water ball
bottle adam which obviously is is
totally inappropriate and wrong and
stupid
um but the kind of thing that happens at
the sporting events
especially when alcohol is involved
after the game kyrie irving was
was uh asked about this incident during
the press conference
and he of course connected it to racism
let's listen
obviously there's been a lot of
conversation about fan interaction with
players
and then there's an instance tonight i'm
just wondering
what you think can be done to prevent
these interactions from happening in the
future
it's unfortunate you know that sports
has come to
a lot of this uh you know kind of
crossroads where
you see in a lot of old ways come up
it's been part of like
it's been part of that it's been that
way in history
in terms of entertainment performers and
sports for a long period of time and
just
underlying racism and just treating
people like they're in a human zoo
you know throwing stuff at people saying
things you know there's a certain point
where it just gets to be too much
underlying racism uh kyrie irving i
don't know what his contract is but
we can assume it's tens of millions of
dollars if not more so he's paid
tens of millions of dollars to play a
game and these fans
pay hundreds of dollars to attend nba
tickets are
not expensive or rather not cheap are
very expensive
um and even more expensive when you
think when you consider the fact that
i mean you shouldn't be spending any
money at all on nba tickets
considering the nba you know hates you
um and has such disdain for the united
states and its citizens and
and most of its fans but still
the tickets are are not cheap
so these fans are paying a lot of money
to come watch him play and they spend a
lot of money on merchandise and jerseys
and everything else
um and that's why they're there and
that's why he's so rich
and yet he connects this to racism
underlying racism it's a it's a human
zoo they're just
these people are just there so i can
entertain them well yes kyrie why else
would they be there
what do you think they're there just for
moral support they are there to be
entertained
it's that's what you do that's your line
of work it's entertainment
people are watching me right now not as
many as many people as watch
watch you but people are watching me
right now
i don't know what their reasons are but
they are watching me i can't be offended
by that what are you doing watching this
what am i a zoo animal here to entertain
you what is this a circus
turn this off i just want to scream
to nobody like i used to do in my car
those were the days that's what it
should be
um yeah this is the line of work you've
chosen
and you get paid handsomely for it
and almost everyone in the country
including all those
supposedly racist fans they would kill
to do what you do for a living
if there's any you know uh any negative
emotions mixed up in that maybe it's
like envy
they're they're they're jealous that
they can't
get paid millions of dollars to play a
game i wish i could get paid millions of
dollars to play a game
it's a line of work that anyone would
love to do you get to do it which is
great
um it's not a charity case so you're one
of the best athletes in the world that's
how you get the job you've worked hard
fantastic all that is good
that's the point you you work your whole
life
to get to this point you achieve it
fantastic
laudable and then you get mad at people
and accuse them of racism because they
come to uh
watch and it's it's a rowdy you know as
you say
zoo environment this is not a defense of
fans throwing you know fans throwing
stuff
getting into fist fights and stuff like
that
that's stupid and trashy and dumb
and uh any any any negative label you
want to put on it it's just not it's not
racist i mean if people were racist
considering the the nba is obviously
predominantly black
um i would think if someone was really
racist
like a white guy hated black people
really racist
probably wouldn't be an nba fan and he
probably wouldn't be spending
hundreds of dollars to go sit at a
stadium
and watch these people who he hates and
are paying millions of dollars more than
he is
play basketball
but obviously everyone has to be a
victim these days and uh just because
you're famous and wealthy and powerful
because power comes with wealth uh that
doesn't mean you're gonna you're gonna
forfeit your victim status
of course all right let's go here number
three matthew mcconaughey is
uh maybe running for governor of texas
and he was
interviewed on a podcast recently um
covered some some ground
i watched a lo i watched like a two
minute segment of it just to see if he
got to the point where he explained why
anyone should actually vote for him for
governor of texas i mean
what exp i know he has experience
pretending to be people
which come to think of it is relevant
experience in politics but
what kind of real leadership experience
does he have what what um
you know what are his qualifications he
doesn't really at least in the clip that
i watch he doesn't he doesn't really
explain that
but they do talk about masking and this
is keep in mind this is a guy who was
recently pictured
um all by himself out in the wilderness
like literally out in the middle of the
woods with a mask on
presumably after being vaccinated
and so not surprisingly he's a big
advocate of masking
and uh here's what he had to say about
that got to make
some sacrifices for larger rewards
tomorrow
i think the best example uh for my mommy
this last year is the damn dispute over
the the mass that got
that got politicized i'm like going come
on man ain't no
you know i'm not believing you're really
scared of this little cotton thing
i feel that takes away your identity and
your freedom
this is a short-term inconvenience for
long-term freedom
come on now there's no data that says
it's
not a good thing no doubt it says it's
harmful yeah let's all take one for the
team here and we like to say we want to
take one for the team we like to say oh
the value of human life is
the epitome that we all no it's not
yeah we won't admit it he's adopted the
joe biden method of argumentation come
on man come on
just not explain why i'm right
come on come on already wear the mask
come on
really compelling stuff very very
convincing not really though
uh yeah as always it doesn't actually
explain why you should wear a mask
even now after being vaccinated while
out in the middle of the woods
why wear the mask it's not enough to say
no no it's not it's not
well why not wear it i can tell you why
not wear it
but that's actually it's not on me to
explain the burden of proof is not on me
if you think people should wear masks
even after being vaccinated even outside
in the woods
burden of proof is on you you're the one
proposing this
radical shift in human behavior
explain why
and saying come on just do it that's not
an explanation
that's not good enough that's not good
enough for me no matter what you're
telling me to do i don't care what it is
i don't care how burdensome it is or how
or not
if you told me to wear a blue shirt
tomorrow
i wear blue shirts all the time no big
deal wearing a blue shirt but i'm still
going to say well
why should i wear a blue shirt you need
to be and if your only answer is say you
know just do it it's not a big deal
well no i'm not going to do it tell me
why i should
and then if you go on to to claim that
it's it it's
will make me safer in all of this now
i'm really going to need an explanation
but matthew mcconaughey no surprise
doesn't provide one
um i i just love how these pro these uh
masking cultists
they try to flip it around and he's
doing the same thing here i hear from
masking cultists all the time
where they pretend that if you don't
wear the mask
then you're the one who's scared what
are you so scared of a mask for i'm not
scared of a mask
i'm not scared no you don't understand
the reason i
don't wear the mask now and have never
really worn it
is because i'm not scared you're the
scared one
wearing a mask is when you're afraid of
something
in fact that's that's almost always the
reason why someone wears a mask
it's about it's about fear or caution or
whatever on your end
no not wearing the mask is about not
being afraid
and so uh those of us who don't wear the
mask our message has been
not you should be afraid of this mask
it's been this you don't need to be
afraid
go live your life like you did before
don't be afraid to breathe fresh air
don't be afraid to be in the same
vicinity as another human being
nothing to be afraid of
now you can argue against that and you
could try to explain why in fact you
should be afraid of the air and you
should be afraid of other people
go ahead and explain it and i'm going to
need some evidence and proof and and
data
it's not enough to simply say oh the
data the data says
show me the data i'm going to need to
actually see it but
that is your argument you are arguing
for fear
i am arguing against fear
that's the way this this breaks down
speaking of not providing reasons to
wear masks also transportation secretary
pete boudij um who also we've never
actually been given an explanation as to
why he is the the secretary of
transportation but he is and um
he was asked about this also this was uh
on sunday about why masking is still
required on public transportation
and he didn't have much of a reason
either but the reason that he gave
as far as it goes was pretty instructive
so let's listen to that
it's memorial day weekend 37 million
americans are expected to travel this
weekend
masks are still required on airplanes
and public transportation despite
new cdc guidance that vaccinated
individuals are safe and do not need to
wear masks indoors or outdoors
divide the administration says you will
always follow the science
what science is there that says that a
fully vaccinated person
needs to wear a mask on on a plane or a
train or a bus
so the public health guidance is a
little bit different for
situations like planes and trains part
of it has to do with the unique
conditions of the physical space
part of it has to do with the conditions
of it being a workplace and folks who
really don't have a choice
about being there the way it is in some
other cases of course
these rules and regulations uh and and
these bodies of guidance always
evolve with the science but the bottom
line is uh we have a set of rules in
place to keep people safe
and i really hope that travelers will
respect
flight attendants bus operators workers
anybody who is
simply doing their job to keep people
safe you think about what
people who work in travel and
transportation think about
what they've been through over the
course of the last year with their jobs
in doubt
and with a lot of challenges on the job
and with a record number at least in
recent
months traveling this weekend let's do
it in a way we can be proud of and show
respect
for all of those workers who are getting
us to where we need to be
let's do it in a way we can be proud of
i agree
so so yeah that's that's why i'm not
wearing the mask
um but he doesn't give a reason he's
invited to give a reason well why
should and this this this again is a
question
this is about specifically people who've
been vaccinated
um and the question is why should they
wear a mask and he doesn't
he vaguely says it's about keeping
people safe okay well how does that
are the vaccines not safe are you saying
the vaccine is not enough
is that what you're saying are you
saying the vaccine is not enough that
it's insufficient
that the vaccine in and of itself is not
protective is that what you're saying
because if that's what you're saying
then please say it
but that's not they'll they'll say
that's not what they're saying the
vaccine is safe
okay then why we need a mask no data no
no nothing not not offering any evidence
but then he gets it
the main thing that he's that he's
proposing is that we should respect it's
about respect
it's not really about safety it's about
respecting people
we should think about what
transportation workers have been through
i'm not sure why they've been through
any more than anyone else has been
through
but um and this idea that it's well it's
their work space yeah but that's any
time you go into a store
anywhere you go if it's not outside
and even then sometimes it is but but
most of the places you go in when you're
going about your
your daily life those are work spaces
also
but you don't have to wear a mask a lot
of those places you do have to wear it
on a plane why is that
it's about respect no not good enough
no i'm not going to wear a mask just out
of respect
i don't really understand the connection
between the mask and respect
but even if i did that's not enough of a
reason
you're asking me to do something to wear
something on my
face
do it out of respect is not good enough
but that's all they have
all right let's go now to reading the
youtube comments this is from jay
moran says i cancelled netflix disney
and no longer watch the nfl i stop
buying coke products i refuse to fly
delta
i'm entering the school board race
starting going to church again i pay
attention to my food and non-food labels
where i don't buy chinese products when
i don't have to
i don't know about anybody else but i've
certainly made a conscious effort to
change a lot of comfortable daily habits
well i think you certainly are in the
minority but you should be applauded for
that
um tony russo says i must admit i taught
in a public school system for over 35
years and my wife taught in public
school for 30 years
if we had children now they would not go
to a public school it's our opinion that
anyone who loves their children should
find an alternate educational option
other than
the public school system i hear this a
lot for actually from people who've
who have worked in public school system
or currently do
saying they don't they wouldn't send
their kids or they don't
and that's always that that always tells
you something
it's like going to a restaurant where
you find out that nobody who works there
eats there
um that that should give you pause
because these are the people who've seen
but
they've seen the kitchen okay they've
seen behind the scenes
and if they don't like it then uh that
should give you pause but but also
let's remember that um it's not as
simple as
not sending your kid to public school
the school that we just talked about the
dalton school in new york city where
they were showing this
graphic video about masturbation to six
year olds that's a private school
that parents spend a lot of money to
send their kids to
so this is a problem that goes way
beyond the public school system
inaccessible cardinals says i guarantee
there are no deaf people on that zoom
call
still they have some homeboy practicing
his signing yeah i thought the same
thing we played on uh on friday
it was a zoom call with a bunch of
teachers in in oregon and
one of them was talking about how if
you're not anti-racist
then you should be fired and you're not
welcome and all that she was the one who
identified as
we and us anyway i thought the same
thing on that zoom call there's like
there's 10 people or something
and there's someone on zoom call signing
doing a sign language interpretation now
there there may have been a
deaf person on the zoom call and that
would explain why the the
the uh sign language interpreter was
there but
i did think the same thing of how much
do you want to bet there's nobody on
that call
who actually is deaf and they have the
sign language interpreter there anyway
as one big giant virtue signal
uh war fans says i saw a quiet place
part two thursday night didn't wear a
mask at all and like most people there
but wanted to know what you thought of
it i thought it was one of the rare
times the sequel was better than the
first one
um yeah i did we we went and saw a quiet
place too on uh
friday night my wife and i we had a date
night
and uh first of all it was great um
i i think it was the first time since
all this started
when when we've had just a normal night
out
we went and this is i know it's not like
this everywhere in the country but this
is how it is now in
nashville we went downtown we got
something to eat and it was
packed downtown no masks
no no capacity limits everything was
open
everything was maskless and uh it was it
just felt normal for the first time this
is the first night that i felt normal
then we went to um
to the movie and even though it's set on
the tickets when we bought them ahead of
time that you need to wear a mask there
was nobody wearing a mask in the theater
uh it was it was great so that part was
wonderful to feel
to have that normalcy back it shouldn't
have taken this long
at all uh we never should have given up
our normalcy to the extent that we did
but
to have it back now was nice anyway as
far as the movie here's what i'll say
about quiet place too
um and you know that i hate most things
but uh but
so so this is this is maybe quite a
statement i thought it was good
and i thought it was one of the best it
was certainly the best horror sequel
of all time and i would say is one of
the best sequels ever made
which probably says more about the quote
the general quality of sequels than it
does about quiet place too
um if there were a lot of really great
sequels out there then this might not
make it its way into the
top ten but but it does i thought it was
i thought it was good my
my one knock on it not gonna give any
spoilers but
um it's it's it's not really a complete
movie
it's more like part one of part three
because you know they're making a third
one and so this is like the first half
of the final chapter
and so it doesn't have much of a of a of
a satisfying conclusion
but i thought it was it was effective
and it's hard to do that with with
horror movies especially i think that's
why
horror sequels are usually pretty bad
it's that once
especially movie like quiet plays but
really any horror movie
um the fear comes from the unknown
and whoever the whatever the villain or
the monster is you haven't seen them
much and so there's that surprise
element and
that's where a lot of the fear and the
suspense and the tension comes from
but when you get to the second movie you
already know you've seen the monster a
lot you know about it
and so how do you keep that tension that
suspense up and they find a way to do it
in the movie that i thought was really
effective finally ryan says hey matt i
went to a quiet place too with a group
of about 30.
none of us wore masks at any point and
the staff never said anything
you went to the movie with 30 people are
you saying there were 30 in the theater
or you went with 30 people to a movie
why would you what why
it's a movie you could i i've been to
movies by myself you could easily sit a
movie by yourself you don't even need
anyone there with you
because you're not supposed to be
talking is the point do you know how
much i would hate you
if i was if if you went to the theater
where my wife and i were
we're sitting down for a nice quiet
movie literally a quiet movie
and then we see a 30 a group of 30
people come in
together that should be illegal
i'm glad there were no masks but um
there there do need to be
size restrictions not covet related on
groups of people attending movies and i
think no you don't need
really the limit should be two i don't
you really don't need anybody
with you at the movie but if you want to
bring one person on a date that's fine
if i'm running the theater you're not
allowed so 30 people roll up i'm gonna
say okay two of you are allowed to come
in
you pick your two draw straws i don't
care you're not all coming in that
should be the rule
but i'm glad you liked the movie all
right now let's talk about
x chair you know i've been talking about
extra for a while now and part of that
the reason is that
if you if you if you sit a lot like i do
throughout the day probably do too much
sitting i think all of us sit more than
we should
you can really tell the difference
between a good chair and a bachelor if
you spend all day sitting in a poorly
constructed chair you're going to pay
for it after the fact and that's why you
need
extra extra has has you covered for your
office chair needs the secret is not
only their patented dynamic
variable lumbar support which offers
great lumbar support to your lower back
but also
thanks to their new xhmt technology you
can get heat and massage therapy while
you're sitting at your desk and get it
all in one package instead of your old
uncomfortable office chair
throw that out in the in the trash where
it belongs and now you can look forward
to spending hours
sitting in the ultimate therapeutic
massager the xhmt delivers heat and
massage technology right to your core
helping increase blood flow muscle
recovery and energy all the perks
that make working from home or the
office a joy if not a joy at least
tolerable
let's set the bar a little bit lower
x-chair is on sale now for a hundred
dollars off go to xchairwalsh.com now
that's the letter x chairwalsh.com
or call one eight four four four x chair
extra has a 30-day guarantee of complete
comfort and you can finance your
purchase
for as little as 30 bucks a month go to
xchairwalsh.com now and use code xwheels
for free
x-wheel bladecasters again that's
xchairwalsh.com
and today like every other day is also a
perfect day to pre-order the
authoritarian moment ben shapiro's
newest book that he wrote in order to
help you
shut down the authoritarian weirdos who
are attempting to control everything we
do
including the way we think and breathe
and the way that our children think and
breathe as we've discussed in it
he gives some background on how we got
to this place and um
and how we can you know go where we
could go from here and how we can get
out of this uh
out of this situation so if you want to
preserve your individual rights and
protect the ones you love from mob rule
then you've got to order the
authoritarian moment
available now at amazon barnes noble or
any other major bookseller
now let's get to our daily cancellation
for our daily cancellation today we take
into consideration a recent viral video
from a woman who insists that although
she's morbidly obese you
must still find her physically
attractive you're not entitled to your
own opinions or preferences
you must fall madly in love with her
this is not a suggestion but rather a
requirement as she clearly explains
listen
hey bestie you're wrong
i think it's time for another adult
pre-k lesson what do you think
all right turn your listening ears on
you catch a bubble in your mouth
good job okay here's the thing
having a preference is something like
i'm looking for a partner who likes
kayaking
or wakes up early in the morning or
loves
pizza but when your preferences
exclude an entire group of marginalized
people that's problematic
okay that's not nice that's not a
preference if you lump all fat people in
one group together as though
they are not very different individuals
that's fat phobic just like lumping all
black people in one group and saying i
don't like black people is racist
and lumping all disabled people in one
group and saying i don't think people in
wheelchairs are hot is ableist do you
understand what i'm saying
no i don't okay so well okay
so you are allowed to prefer a partner
who likes kayaking which
thankfully i think lets us off the hook
because something tells me she's not
exactly an avid kayaker
but those loopholes aside it seems that
our friend here has stumbled on a rather
unique pickup line
part of me wishes that i had thought of
this when i was single like ma'am
you are morally obligated to find me
attractive now come and date me at once
lest you be guilty of problematic and
exclusionary behavior
but something tells me i would have uh
struck out as badly with that line as
i'm sure she does
the only difference is that i would have
been arrested for harassment and
stalking on top of it
now a few points to make here first of
all this woman and my 12 seconds of
research tells me that her name is lexie
has uh and the research was just looking
at the bottom of the of the video there
where it says her name
has a she has a she has a problem that
goes beyond her weight
if lexi finds that most people don't
want to be around her it probably is
because of her god-awful personality
i for one would rather take a bath and
battery acid
than be stuck in a room with her for any
length of time
that's got nothing to do with her
appearance it has everything to do with
her demeanor her attitude
tone of voice and just way of being
this is something that anyone who
struggles to find a partner should take
into consideration before wondering
whether you're being discriminated
against based on your physical features
please reflect on the possibility
that you might be a nagging miserable
shrew
now it can be hard even for the most
attractive person to find or at least
maintain
relationships if they have a repulsive
personality
but if you're not a top-notch physical
specimen and most of us aren't
and you also have the character and
general disposition of the wicked witch
of the west
then you you really have put yourself in
a hole with only yourself to blame for
it
second point she says that you aren't
allowed to exclude entire groups of
people
from your sexual preference but that of
course is exactly what a sexual
preference
is that's what any kind of preference is
actually preferences
exclude by definition all preferences do
any preference is exclusionary and
discriminatory that's the whole point
you're preferring one thing over another
or one person over another
as for sexual preference specifically
gay men exclude her because she's a
woman
is she going to berate them for that
well she might i guess as we've seen
for years the left insisted that
sexuality is innate and immutable
it can't be changed and it's not the
result of choice but more recently
they've decided that their own arguments
no longer hold
your sexuality can become problematic if
it excludes
so-called marginalized groups a gay man
who isn't attracted to a woman who
identifies as a man
is now transphobe a straight man who
isn't attracted to a man who identifies
as a woman
is also a transphobe anybody who isn't
attracted to an obese person is fat
phobic
anyone who isn't attracted to shrill
hectoring condescending scolds like lexi
is whatever kind of phobic that applies
to
your sexuality is not your own business
it is not a private matter anymore
as the left had previously insisted they
will decide
who you should be attracted to and quite
often coincidentally enough
the person putting themselves in the
position to make this choice for you
will decide that you should be attracted
to them personally
funny how that works you know it's like
well i've run the numbers and i've done
the calculations and it turns out
that in order to not be a bigot you're
supposed to be turned on by uh
what does it say here oh me sorry i
don't make the rules
well i guess i do actually third point
briefly referring back to the first
um this seems to be something that a lot
of people do even if they aren't on the
left
when people have trouble forming and
maintaining relationships both sexual
and platonic
they develop a victim complex deciding
that the problem
in their personal and romantic lives is
that everyone else is being mean to them
and this only exacerbates the problem
because nobody wants to be around
someone with a victim complex even
people with victim complexes
don't want to be around other people
with victim complexes in fact people
with victim complexes especially don't
want to be around other people to victim
complexes
because then it becomes a zero-sum game
a sort of victimhood competition
the self-determined victim becomes all
the more isolated as a result and their
victim mentality only hardens and
spreads and
metastasizes over time so if you're
looking around and finding that most
people don't want to be around you
don't find you appealing or attractive
on any level
you could start pointing fingers and
making demands or you can begin the
difficult work of changing yourself
and this process should be one that
includes both the exterior and the
interior both physical and spiritual
although this is hard and painful and it
requires the kind of honest
self-assessment that most people don't
have the wherewithal to conduct
the good thing is that you actually have
control over yourself
yourself is a thing you can change by
the grace of god
you can't really force anyone else to
change
all you can do is scream at them as they
back ever farther away
until you're all alone yelling into the
void
it's up to you which strategy you choose
we know which one lexi has chosen and
for that reason today she is of course
cancelled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nikka geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 a popular
children's cartoon teams up with a drag
queen
a first grade teacher instructs
six-year-olds to pleasure themselves
and an australian journalist exposes dr
fauci's involvement with the origins of
the pandemic check it out on the michael
knoll show
[Music]